[THEME PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Thanks, everyone, for coming to
"Treasured Lands" presentation.
Please give a warm
welcome to Dr. QT Luong.
[APPLAUSE]
QT LUONG: Thank you,
[? Phil, ?] for inviting me.
It's an honor for me
to talk at Google,
and I'm grateful that you took
some time out of your busy day
to come and listen to me.
I was a more unlikely person
than you to photograph
the national parks.
I was born in Paris
from Vietnamese parents,
and I grew up as a city kid.
My world changed
when college friends
took me high up the
high peaks of the Alps.
I discovered wilderness
for the first time
and made a connection
with nature.
Here in California, we are
very fortunate to have access
to many wild places.
But in France,
they were all gone,
save for the high mountains.
I took up photography as a
means to bring back to France,
and family who
could not get there,
the beauty of the high
peaks of the Alps.
Here, this is Mont Blanc, the
highest peak in Western Europe.
I was just snapping a quick
shot before hurrying down
to beat the storm.
At first, my goal was just
to document my climbs.
But I began to notice
that, sometimes, light
could create some magic.
A Canadian friend of
mine donate me this book,
and I realized that the type of
photographies that I was doing
could be elevated
to an art form.
This was my last climb in the
Alps in the summer of 1992--
beautiful light at sunset.
But wait.
What were you doing
there at sunset
when you were supposed
to have an alpine start?
It was a photo trip.
I had begun to learn
more about the light
and play with this
way of changing it.
This was my last trip in the
Alps because the next winter,
I would move to Berkeley.
I would work on the
first self-driving car
project in California.
I'd just finished my PhD--
that's the book that
grew out of it--
and I was looking for a
short-term post-doc stay
in the US.
At that time, I didn't know
much about the geography
of this country.
But other climbers had told me
that there were some good rocks
to climb in Yosemite.
So of all the great US
research universities,
I picked Berkeley because it
was the closest to Yosemite.
I didn't know anything about
the national parks, either.
But I was told that
somewhere in Yosemite,
there was a
3,000-foot-high cliff,
the tallest in North America.
I discovered there a vertical
wilderness at a scale new
for me.
The climbs took several days.
To sleep, we had to bring
along those platforms, which
are called portaledges--
very comfortable.
You just have to make sure that
you don't roll in your sleep.
So I didn't fall out
of the portaledge,
and I managed to
snap a few pictures.
So the key to
climbing photography
is that you have to try to be
at the same level of the climber
or above.
In the spring of the same year,
the mountain called again,
and I set up my sight on Denali,
the tallest peak in North
America, at 20,000 feet.
What makes a climb
of Denali special
is that it is a combination
of mountaineering and Arctic
expedition.
Temperatures can go
down to minus 40.
Climbers build snow walls
to protect their tents
against a fierce wind.
You start with supplies
for three weeks.
That's the time it
takes to acclimatize,
climb the mountain, while
waiting through storms.
It's too heavy to
carry on your backpack.
So in addition to the
backpack, you drag a sled.
I didn't freeze to death
and made it to the summit,
with glaciers extending
to the horizon.
The immensity of the mountains
were at a scale new to me.
That same fall, I
visited Death Valley.
I'd never been in
a desert before,
so that was also a new
environment for me.
The geological
formation fascinated me.
Previously, I was
standing on the top
of the coldest
mountain on earth,
the top of North America.
Now, I was at the lowest point
in the Western Hemisphere,
where the hottest temperature
on earth was recorded.
I began to realize how
much diversity there
was in the national parks.
I was able to appreciate
that because I'd
been to both places.
Yet, there were
also similarities.
You see here is a
[INAUDIBLE] echoing
the glaciers in the valley.
Each park is highly
individual and unique.
But taken together, they
are all interrelated.
So I'm a self-taught
photographer
and learn mostly
by reading books
and by looking at
books of photography.
I began to study the
American tradition
of landscape
photography, which is
much stronger than in France.
I visited local museums,
and the prints that I saw
were the most beautiful
I've ever set my eyes on.
When I came back from
Denali, I was somehow
disappointed by my pictures.
So it was time to try
to learn a new approach.
I decided to try to photograph
with the same camera
as the old masters, so
a large format camera.
So here's one of the first
images I made in Death Valley.
When I came home and
looked at the transparency,
I was astonished
to see that there
was more details that
I could see than when
I was standing at the scene.
And to give you, beside
that, with an example
from a very different
environment-- the redwoods
of Northern California.
If you come between
mid-May and mid-June,
the rhododendrons are in bloom.
They are a very small
part of the image,
but important
nevertheless because they
create the correct contrast.
With a large format
camera, I do not
have to frame tightly
the blooms for the detail
to be there because--
see-- so much resolution.
So one example here to show
you is that, in those images,
I do not have to direct the
viewer because there's so much
detail that they can explore the
image for themselves as if they
were standing at the scene.
So here's a few details
from that image.
Each of them makes an
interesting nature picture
of their own.
So one technical
detail is that you
can notice that the
trees in the background
are as sharp as the
reeds in the foreground.
So the second technical detail--
so the horizon here is
fairly low in the image,
yet you see the trees
remain parallel.
And there in the redwood
scene, the horizon was low,
and we have parallel trees.
If we had converging trees,
as would have happened
if I had pointed
the camera up, that
would create a different
mood for the picture
with less of a sense of calm.
So the large format
camera has bellows
that connect the
front and the back,
and that allows me to include
tall objects without pointing
the camera up, and that is
what maintains the parallelism.
So here, the simple adjustment
that you have is a tilt.
So the tilt allows you to
change the plane of focus.
With a regular camera, the
plane is a vertical plane,
which means that you focus
at a fixed distance, either
a foreground or a background.
Here, I was able to
choose as a plane of focus
a plane that goes from
the reed to the hill
and, therefore, maintaining
everything sharp.
So those movements are
available in a limited
way with tilt and shift lenses.
But what's unique to
the large format camera
is the size of the negative.
So here, you see the back
of my camera is 5 by 7.
That's the exact
size of the negative.
Here, you see a transparency.
So this transparency is 5 by 7.
It is five times, in
linear dimensions,
the size of 35
mil or full frame,
25 times in surface area.
That's what gives detail
and provides large format
photography its
descriptive power.
So when you photograph, you
have to use a dark cloth
because the image on the
ground glass is very dim.
Everything is manual,
not only focus, exposure,
but also film transport.
So there's many
occasions to mess up.
So each holder holds two pieces
of film, one on each side.
So you insert it on the camera.
When you're ready to
make the exposure,
you have to remove
the dark slide so
that the film can be exposed.
And then, you have to be
careful not to double expose it,
since there's two of them.
So in order to do that, you
put the dark slide in reverse,
so you remember which
side you've exposed.
So with all the time it
takes to set up an image,
does it make sense just to
shoot one without backup?
So in general, I
shoot two pictures
for the same composition.
With the cost of film
and processing labs,
it adds up to $20.
So here's a picture.
It was taken in the
Tetons in winter.
This type of photography
promotes a very deliberate
approach.
This helps me communicate
how the land reveals itself
to you in a state of
heightened awareness.
So I've been talking quite a bit
about large format photography.
But the disciplines
that I learned
can be transferred to
other equipment, as well.
If you slow down, that
would be the thing
that will do the most to
help your photography.
And you can, maybe,
pretend your camera
is very heavy and
cumbersome, if it helps.
Those two
[? strains-- ?] my desire
to see the diversity of the
national park and large format
photography--
inspired me to embark on the
project to photograph each
of them in large format.
So we have, currently,
16 national park.
Nine of them are
located in California.
Have you visited, any of
you, visited each of them?
And to give you a
quick tour of them,
and since it's a tech
talk, there will be,
maybe, a few photo tips.
To many viewers it is, maybe,
the most accessible viewpoint
in the national parks.
It was made famous
by Ansel Adams.
I conceived this image as
an homage to Ansel Adams
because he'd photographed
it so many times.
But I wanted to make some
things that he hadn't
made at that location, which is
an image which would work only
in color and not
in black and white.
So I envisioned the
maximum color contrasts
that would happen with the
orange of sunsets in the cloud
and the blue fog in the valley.
And this was the image
that I visualized.
It took me dozens of visits, but
eventually, I made it happen.
So that's the power of
previsualization for you.
Lassen Volcanic National Park.
So for this image, I
photograph at sunrise.
The more specific the
moment, the more universal
is the image.
I had to photograph
right at that moment
because after the
sun would come out,
the shadows would
ruin the foreground.
And I use a graduated
neutral density filter
to control the brightness
of the horizon.
Joshua Tree National Park.
So beginner is often
told to photograph
with the sun on their back.
But here, that's a backlight
that makes the image work.
It's very interesting light.
It makes the spine
of the cacti glow.
So those cacti are called
the jumping cholla cactus,
and they're not called
that for nothing.
When I was there,
fumbling in the dark,
I brushed against one of them.
I didn't want to
try to dislodge it
for fear of getting my
fingers stuck, as well.
So with the sunrise
quickly approaching,
I kept photographing with
one lodged in my behind.
So only after it was all over,
I strolled back to my car
and teased the spiny
thing out with pliers.
But the best tool
for that is a comb.
And my advice to
you is to carry one
when you hike in the desert.
Pinnacles National Park.
It was the 59th national park.
It was designated in 2013.
The next day after it
became a national park,
I came at dawn so
that I would be sure
that I'd be the first
to photograph the 59.
But this image is taken at dusk.
Often, photographers leave
right after the sun has set.
It's too early.
The best light often
comes after sunset.
So you have to stay
until it is dark,
but make sure that
you bring a light.
Redwood National Park.
So the smaller subject
needs softer light.
Larger subject needs
stronger light.
So for the forest, often,
overcast is the best light.
But even so, it
wouldn't have been
enough here because
the tops of the trees
would have been too white.
So what makes the picture
work here is the fog.
It conveys a sense
of death and mystery.
So try to seek
weather conditions.
Kings Canyon National Park.
So unlike the redwoods, the
sequoias are mountain trees.
I wanted to convey that by
shooting them in the snow.
The first time I came, since
there was no snow on the trees,
the scene didn't have
a wintry atmosphere.
So I came back a second
time, right after a storm.
But as the sun came
up, the snow started
to fall from the branches.
I drove back home six
hours without making
a single large
format photograph.
So third time, I came
right during the storm
wearing full mountaineering
gear and using snowshoes.
I was able, at least,
to get the image.
So persistence pays.
Sequoia National Park, the
sister of Kings Canyon.
You see here a very similar
subject to the previous one.
The base of sequoia trees--
very similar composition.
But the mood is very different.
In photography,
light is everything.
So the light that
you're seeing here
is the light that I
talked about before--
after sunset,
before it gets dark.
It's a very beautiful
light for that scene
because it is at
the same time soft--
so no hard shadows--
and directionals
reveals the texture.
Channel Islands National
Parks, a set of five islands.
The closest is only
one hour off the coast
of Southern California, but
it could be a world apart.
They are home to
plants which are
found nowhere else
on the planet,
such as the giant coreopsis.
So this viewpoint
is, in my opinion,
the best view on the
whole west coast.
But it is more
beautiful if you come
when the flower is blooming.
At other times,
everything is brown,
like the rest of California.
So for trips, if you want
to see the best of nature,
it is always
important to research
and try to time your trip.
Death Valley
National Park again.
So maybe you've
noticed, but this
is the fifth image of Death
Valley that I show you.
And all of them were
taken in midday.
So midday is possibly
the most difficult time
to photograph a landscape
and, particularly, the desert.
So how did I make that work?
I looked for a dune which
had a steep slope which
was graced by the sun.
I shot backlit to
accentuate the texture.
So in the back, those
mountains with textures
echoes that of the dunes.
But yet, they are darker, so
they don't draw the eye away
from the dunes.
And for the same reason,
I excluded the sky
because it would
have been brighter
and drew your eye away.
So beyond California, we
have many national parks.
There's total of 60 of them.
Here's [INAUDIBLE] that I
photographed two weeks ago.
The national parks extend
from the southern hemisphere--
so this is our southernmost
national park in American
Samoa--
to north of the Arctic Circle.
This is our northernmost
national park, Gates
of the Arctic National Park.
So like many of the
Alaskan national parks,
there's no roads or even trails.
So when I made
this image, I took
advantage of a
five-minute window
during which the clouds lifted.
For the rest of my stay,
they would not lift again.
To get there, I flew
from the Bay Area
to Anchorage and
then to Fairbanks.
In Fairbanks, I took
a commuter plane
to reach Bettels, a community
which can be reached only
by plane in the summer.
And there, we chartered a
plane to land us on a lake.
And we backpacked for
two days and a half
to arrive at the
base of the peak.
To show you a few more behind of
scenes from my Alaskan trips--
so this scene looks,
also, very wild.
But actually, it is
the best place for you
to walk on the glacier.
It is only one hour from a road.
It is in Wrangell-St.
Elias National Park, which
is our largest national park.
It is the size of
six Yellowstone.
I wanted to convey the
immensity of the place
and of the mountain.
And for that, I needed
a higher viewpoint,
which I sought by climbing
the mountains that you
see on the right.
So that's me with a backpack
typical of Alaskan trips.
So I have my backcountry
camping gear, my 5 by 7 camera,
and a 35 mil system, too.
It adds up to 70 pounds.
The glacier looks
flat from a distance,
but it is full of
nooks and crannies,
such as this canyon carved
by a glacier stream.
You can even go down
under the glacier
if you're a relatively fit
hiker, even without experience
in mountaineering.
Local guides can take you
on a half-day trip there.
So crossing the glacier
was only a few miles,
but it took me several
days because I had
to zigzag between crevasses.
The next day, after
setting up my camp
at the base of the
mountain, I planned
to climb the mountain
as a day trip.
But in the afternoon,
it turned out
that it was too hazy because
of distant wildfires,
and the light wasn't very good.
So I resolved to bivy on
the top of the mountain
without my climbing gear.
But fortunately, I
had my stove, so I
was able to make myself
some warm tea before going
to bed for a very cold night.
So the next morning, I
got my second chance.
Here's a picture.
Was it worth it?
Glacier Bay National Park.
So far, to explore
the national park,
I had used, mostly, my
mountaineering skills.
But Glacier Bay is
a marine wilderness.
When Captain George Vancouver
sailed there 200 years ago,
that very spot was a
solid sheet of ice.
200 years later,
the glaciers have
retreated 65 miles,
which is the largest
glacial retreat in history.
So to explore those parks,
I had to learn new skills--
in the case of
Glacier Bay, paddling.
The glaciers that you see in
the background look smaller,
but our kayak, here, give you a
better indication of its scale.
The National Park Service
has done a great job
at helping us explore
the parks and even
at such a remote
location as Glacier Bay,
they provide a shuttle boat.
And so it transports
you midway, so you
have to paddle only 30
miles to the glaciers.
So this was a trip in which
we packed for two weeks.
And believe it or not, all this
stuff fits into a double kayak.
Everything was wrapped
into plastic bags
because it had been
drizzling all morning.
Usually, I travel solo, by
myself, but for that trip,
I was very fortunate to
have found a partner.
And actually, I recruited
him at a slide presentation
just like this one.
So come to see me if
you want to take a trip.
And I was fortunate to have him
because the tides in Glacier
Bay is so strong that
if I was by myself,
I might have been swept away.
So we started very
early in the morning.
We had planned to paddle
until it got dark.
But it was Alaska.
And it was mid-May.
So we ended up setting
our camp past midnight.
And by the time we were done,
I noticed that the light
was getting brighter.
So I didn't want to go to bed.
It was so beautiful,
I strolled down,
and I saw an iceberg which
was 100 feet out in the water.
I knew at the speed at
which the tide was moving,
it would be soon
out of the water.
So I walked in the water
until it was knee deep.
I set up the camera, and I was
able to make this image just
as the tide line
was reaching it.
So this was on the
first day of my trip.
But it still remains my
favorite image of the trip
because it reminds me of
that particular state of mind
I was after being
awake for 24 hours.
So on our way to Kobuk
Valley National Park,
our most remote and least
visited national park,
the year when we visited, Kobuk
Valley saw 4,000 visitors.
By contrast, Yosemite
had four million.
There's [INAUDIBLE] village,
downstream of the park,
and take off through
another melt plain.
But we thought it would
be a leisurely float.
But the river was very
placid, and from time to time,
when the wind blows hard,
if we didn't paddle hard,
we would float backwards.
Kobuk Valley is known for its
sand dune, which is a curiosity
north of the Arctic Circle.
So when I set up the camera,
and I photograph in the park,
I choose my goal to be the first
to photograph all the national
parks-- it was 57 back then--
in large format.
And it was the year 2002.
My project to photograph
the national parks
had been self-funded, so far.
Back until that
time, I was still
working as a computer scientist.
But in 2001, I set up a website.
So back then, there was no
Flickr, no social media.
And I was hoping to be
able to sell photograph
through the website.
Other photographers were
skeptical but, eventually,
thanks to a little-known
search engine called Google,
I was able to get some
decent amount of traffic,
and it allowed me to sell enough
prints and license images.
For a moment, Terra Galleria
was the most visited
of all individual
photographers' website.
So in the year 2007, I was
able to follow my passion
and go into
photography full-time.
It allowed me to do
more repeated visits
to the national parks to cover
them in different seasons,
visit all their corners.
I would end up doing
more than 300 parks
visit for that project, an
average of five per parks.
There was a thing which
happened in the 21st century is
that digital
photography took off.
I bought a second
full-frame camera,
and it opened the door
for night photography,
which, previously, it was
impossible to photograph
the star field with film because
film was not sensitive enough.
Night photography offers even
more creative possibilities
than daytime photography
because, in addition
to all the other variables,
you have the phase of the moon.
And visiting the parks
at night restores a sense
of awe and mystery
that sometimes
was lost in crowded
spots during the day.
Moonlight is just like sunlight.
Here is a moonset.
Also, you don't see it
with your naked eye.
The light of moonset is warm,
just like the light of sunset.
Another thing which the faster
shutter speed of digital
made possible was to properly
capture the northern lights.
To make this image, I drove
on the Dalton highway,
which is one of the most
dangerous roads in North
America.
It's 400 miles long, with
services only at one point,
called Coldfoot,
appropriately, population 13.
At one point during the trip,
at midday, the thermometer
had minus 32.
So another thing that I
did to extend the project
beyond landscape photography
with a small camera
is to photograph wildlife.
But still, I had the sensibility
of a large format photographer.
Instead of trying to
use telephoto lenses,
I tried to get closer
to the animals.
This is Dall sheep in
Denali National Park.
So actually, the way to
get close to the animals
is often to let
them approach you.
So if you stay still,
they will come to you,
and then, you will be able to
photograph them more closely,
as in this image.
So here's one exception, when
I approached the subject.
This was in Zion National Park--
not your typical bird picture.
It was taken with a wide-angle
lens, a 24 millimeter,
on a tripod with a
multi-second exposure.
So why is that longer?
Because it was in
a dark slot canyon.
To reach that spot, we had
to use a technique called
canyoneering, and
it was a skill set
I learned during the project.
So one of the thing which is
surprising in those hidden
canyons is that, although
the temperature in the desert
hovers in the hundreds, if
you don't wear a wetsuit,
you get hypothermic in no time
because the water is freezing,
and you have to swim through.
Speaking of water, here is the
other half of Channel Island
National Park.
This is a kelp forest,
the fastest growing
plants on earth.
And here, on the other coast,
Biscayne National Park,
our lowest national park,
maximum elevation nine feet.
95 percent of the
park is underwater.
So to photograph that,
I had to scuba dive.
So in underwater
photography, likewise, you
have to try to photograph
at a close distance
because otherwise,
the picture is not
clear because of the water.
And if you try to
chase the fish,
you will just end up
photographing their tails.
And the same is true,
also, if you go snorkeling.
Katmai National Park has
the largest concentration
of brown bears in the world.
So unlike the previous
animals, those are not the ones
that you want to get close to.
But sometimes things happen.
So maybe the bear was curious
about the strange device which
are pointed to
them all the time.
But fortunately for me, he was
more interested in photography
than having me for breakfast.
So I'd set up the
large format camera
to try to take the picture
of the big footprints
because you can't use that
camera to photograph the bears
themselves.
So I was under the
dark cloth when
I felt a presence behind me.
Turning away, I see the bear.
He was at the same
distance from me
as I am from you in
the front hall here.
So I had to remember those
lessons that they teach you
at the visitor center
that you have to try
not to run because it triggers
their hunting instinct.
So I walked back slowly and
made it to behind a tree.
The other thing with
digital photography
is that now, the digital
cameras double as video cameras.
And so I've shown you how
I extended the project
beyond large format photography
into wildlife and night
photography.
And here I'm going
to show you a video,
another art form that
I've begun to explore.
But before that, I'm going
to explain to you what you're
going to see in the video.
So Hawaii Volcanoes National
Park is home to Kilauea.
It is the most active
volcano on earth,
been erupting
continuously for 40 years.
And it is also the most
user-friendly volcano on earth.
There's no place
like that on earth
where you can get as close and
personal because the explosion
is not eruptive.
The lava flows very slowly.
This image was taken
with a wide-angle lens.
I got as close as
I could to the lava
before I could feel the
heat burning my skin.
The Halemaumau crater-- this
image was taken in 2001.
So back then, you could get
to the rim of the crater.
In the background,
you see Mauna Loa,
which is a 4,000-foot mountain.
Despite what its rounded
shape would lead you to think,
it's so rounded because
the lavas that created
it flowed very smoothly.
It's called a shield volcano.
But one decade later, the
volcano has reawakened.
And then in the crater,
there's now a lava lake.
At night, you just
see a plume of smoke.
When you come at day,
you see a plume of smoke.
But when you come at
night, the lava lake
illuminates the plume of
smoke to create that glow.
So the lava flows mostly through
underground tubes to the ocean.
But if you come
at the right time,
you can see [INAUDIBLE] on the
surface and, from time to time,
into the ocean.
So if you want to
witness that, you
have to check out the
National Park Service website.
They have posted
daily conditions
because most of
the time, the lava
doesn't flow on the surface.
So when the lava
hits the ocean, it
creates new land
right in front of you.
And as it cools
down, it's something
that I found very moving.
After everybody had
left, I stayed overnight
to create a time-lapse at night.
So I had a tent there because
it's very windy at that spot.
So opposite of that
volcano that I showed you,
Mauna Loa, it could
be another planet.
This was the most daring
hike that I'd ever done.
It was 30 miles, and I
didn't see a single plant.
And I didn't, also, see
a single person there.
It could have been
another planet.
I expected the top
to be flat form,
but, actually, it
has this huge crater
with 600 feet vertical walls.
I stayed there, on
the top, all night
in order to make a time-lapse.
Also, it was Hawaii.
At night, my water bottle froze.
Here's a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
QT LUONG: So video is
great, but it still
remains in the digital realm.
And for me, it's very
important to have
a physical manifestation
of the photograph
because there's so much more
resolution in the print.
And viewing things
in the world is
different than looking
at a computer screen.
So I mounted a
travel exhibit, which
traveled across the country.
Here's an installation at
the Boston Museum of Science.
It was viewed, maybe, by
hundreds of thousands.
But exhibit still go,
still come and go.
On the other hand, book stays
and can inspire generations.
So the year 2016 marked
the 100th anniversary
of the National Park Service.
I wanted to celebrate
the occasion
by releasing my own book.
So book travel through
the ages, indeed.
I was inspired by 100-year-old
book which is called
"The National Park Portfolio."
It was a main tool
that Stephen Mather
used to lobby for the creation
of the National Park Service
in 1916.
Also, it says Department of
the Interior on the cover.
He funded the first printing
out of his own pocket.
So Stephen Mather would go on
to become the first director
of the National Park Service.
The book was called "The
National Park Portfolio"
because it consisted
of nine booklets-- one
for each of the national parks.
The first characteristic of
the portfolio that struck me
was that it provided a
very complete description
of each park.
So here's Stephen
Mather's own assessment.
At that time, there were
just nine national parks.
So that was something which
was fairly easy to do.
Now, it is much
more of a challenge.
The second characteristic of
the portfolio that struck me
was that it was an
invitation to visit the park.
So you see how to reach
the national parks.
And he's very emphatic,
"Yosemite belongs to you."
So inspired by those
two characteristic,
I wanted to make a book
about the national park
which would be
very comprehensive
and which, also, would be
an invitation to visit.
So here is some specifications
from my book proposal.
No traditional publisher
wanted to take on that project
because it was too ambitious.
So by the summer of 2015,
no progress had been made.
And so I decided to
try to do it by myself.
I hired a publishing consultant.
Two months after,
the consultant quit
because he thought that
the project was too risky.
So I want to show you the
vision that I had for the book.
So of course it would cover
all the national parks,
but it would also give equal
weight to the lesser gems
than to the more
well-known national parks.
And I will give you an
example a bit later.
So for each park, I also
wanted to cover it in detail
to give justice not only
to the diversity found
in the national park system
but also to the diversity found
in each park.
So the example
that I'll give you
is from Lassen
Volcanic National Park.
It is always a place where
I can go in the summer
when I'm looking for
an uncrowded outing
to a national park.
I can find there the beautiful
landscape of the Sierra
but, at the same time,
Lassen has a vast array
of geological features.
It is the only
national park that
has the four types of
volcanoes-- so all those.
So it's 10 images from Lassen
Volcanic National Park.
This is the summit
of Mount Lassen.
It bears the scars of the
20th century eruption.
Here, you see a plug dome
volcano above Helen Lake.
And here, that composite
volcano above Reflection Lake.
Basalt cliffs giving rise
to Kings Creek Falls.
And a shield volcano
against Juniper Lake.
That's the Cinder Cones
that we have seen before.
And at Bumpass Hell,
a geothermal area
which looks like a
mini Yellowstone.
And there are Devil's Kitchen,
another geothermal area,
which is much less developed.
So the images not only will
tell of a natural history story
but, also, you can see on
the map that each of them
was chosen to represent a
specific location on the park.
And to get there, they cover all
the five entrances of the park.
So other photography
books, coffee table books,
they can inspire you with
beautiful photography
but, often, they
leave you wondering
where the locations are.
So in "Treasured Land,"
I wanted, for each image,
to provide a paragraph of text
that explains in detail where
the location, how to get
there, what is the best
time of the day, of the
year, and maybe, from time
to time, some photographic tips
or some of my own experiences.
So many in the publishing
industry were very skeptical.
But by using a hybrid
publishing model
between self-publishing
and traditional publishing,
I was eventually able
to realize my vision
and offer the book for a very
reasonable price for what
you get.
So "Treasured Lands"
is my opus magnum.
I set out to create
the best photography
book about the national parks.
So have I succeeded?
I'll let you judge.
But I only say that one year
after publication, the book
went into its third printing.
So I'm going to conclude here
with the section of Yosemite
from the book.
And the idea is that, even in
the most well-trodden places,
there is still something
new to discover.
So on the right, [INAUDIBLE]
views that all of you know.
On the left are views that I
bet you haven't seen before.
So where is that view?
If you look at the valley
views there on the left,
there is a waterfall
very high, there.
This waterfall is
called Ribbon Falls.
It is the tallest one-drop
waterfall in North America--
1,600 feet.
Yosemite Falls is higher,
but it has three tiers.
And these are user
trails that lead you
to the base of that waterfall.
You can stand in a
huge amphitheater
where the water drops
directly on your head.
It is a very awesome and
very cold experience.
Speaking of Yosemite Falls, even
for a very well-known landmark,
there's still something
new to discover.
Most photographers and
visitors stop at the bridge.
But if you continue
maybe 10 minutes past it
on the talus field, you'll
come to this viewpoint,
where you see upper falls
and lower falls in alignment.
So the picture
was made at night.
It is a moonbow--
a rainbow created
by the full moon.
This part is exceedingly
wet in the spring.
To make this image, I had
to use a special device that
rotates very fast to throw
out water off the lens.
So I'm going to
conclude by saying
that I'm hoping that this
presentation has given you
a taste of the diversity
found in the national parks.
Exploring the national parks
has been an incredible adventure
for me.
It has brought much
joy to my life,
and my hope is that you can
experience for yourself the joy
that I experience in the park.
So the National Park
Service has two goals.
One is to conserve the lands
for future generations.
The other is to
make it enjoyable
for present generations.
They have made a very good
job at accommodating those two
objectives.
So everything that you
saw there is there for you
and belongs to you.
You don't have to
lug a heavy camera.
You don't even have to venture
very far from the road.
So above all, I hope
that my photography
has inspired you to visit
your park for yourself
and, if the experience
has enriched
your life, to do something in
return for your national parks.
And I thank you in
advance for that.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So I think we have time for a
few questions, if you'd like.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the great presentation.
I'm down to 19 parks, so
you beat me, for sure.
I hope to cover all the
parks at some point in time.
So two-part question.
One is, what kind of processing
do you do of these images?
And now there are the digital
camera, full-frame cameras,
are you inclined more to
take full-frame pictures
with a digital camera
versus the traditional ones?
What are the pros and cons?
QT LUONG: Sure.
So first, processing.
In case of the film images,
the post-processing that I do
is mostly to try to
match the transparency.
So the transparency is
a transmissive medium.
The light goes through it.
The print is a
reflective medium.
So they have different
characteristics.
And so I try to match experience
of looking at the transparency
and the print.
So in order to do that, I
do some minor adjustments.
In general, I do not do
radical post-processing.
Of course, when I
shoot with digital,
I use [INAUDIBLE]
and then you have
to process a file to bring out
the color and the contrast.
But in general, that's pretty
much the adjustments that I do.
So local adjustments
of color and contrast.
As for digital since
large format photography--
so when I started the project,
if you wanted high resolution,
there was no alternative
to large format.
Now, of course, digital
give you very good quality
in a very small package.
And so now, these
days, I actually
do most of my
photography in digital.
But in the book, I would say,
it's about half and half.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My five-year-old
has done 12 parks,
so I'm hoping she'll get
to all the 59 in good time.
One of the things I was
very curious to know
is if you've seen the art form
emerge from traditional film
into digital.
While we all see the quality of
pictures change along with it,
how is the experience in
national parks changed?
Now, with more
digital photographers
out there, more people wanting
to experience national parks,
have you seen a
significant change
in how the national
parks themselves
have evolved to handle that?
QT LUONG: Yes.
I would say that
photography has definitely
become more popular with
digital photography.
And now, some of the spots
that I photograph in the '90s,
usually, I was the only
photographer there,
or there were just
a couple of them.
A spot like, for instance,
the Mesa Arch in Canyonlands,
I've been told that, now, if you
want to stake a spot you have
to come several
hours before sunrise,
and, in general, there would
be a crowd of several dozen.
So indeed, I would say that
some of the more popular spots
have become more crowded.
There's no denying it.
But I've been
trying, as of late,
to explore mostly in the
backcountry of the parks.
And the things
that I've found is
that if you go
further than maybe one
hour from the trailhead, the
parks remain largely uncrowded.
And if you go further than that,
and you go into lesser-know
areas--
some of which I've tried
to feature in the book
to give you some ideas--
then, you can really have
the place for yourself.
AUDIENCE: So a question online.
How do you decide to go to
a particular national park?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
actually my question, too.
So for example, I
guess, say, for example,
you might want to
visit a national park
for a particular season.
But then, what, exactly,
days do you pick?
Do you look at the weather
forecast and things
like that before deciding,
OK, I should go now,
or I should go next week?
QT LUONG: So, in
general, on the trips,
actually, I try to visit
more than one park.
So it's not, I would say--
with some exceptions-- it's
not last-minute planning.
So I pick the time more
based on the season, I'd say,
for instance, the
autumn or the spring.
And then, after that,
I can delay my trip,
say, by a few days,
or choose to visit
the parks in a different order,
according to the weather.
And for instance, if I see
that it's going to be cloudy,
then I'm going to
go to somewhere
where I'm going to photograph
in the forest or something.
Or conversely, if I see
that there will be no cloud,
then I'm going to plan to
do some night photography,
for instance.
So I stay flexible when
I get to the location.
But it's the long-term
planning, I would say,
which is more important.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So I notice that you're
starting to use drones.
Could you talk about
how that changes things?
QT LUONG: Well, for
one thing, drones are
prohibited in national parks.
So I haven't done
any drone photography
in the national park
for that reason.
But for my other projects,
I've, indeed, taken to them.
And I think they are
really great because they
afford you to do
aerial photography
on the spur of a moment.
So you don't have to do advance
planning and book a flight.
And it is, of course,
much less expensive.
And then, it really
allows you to have
a new perspective on the
land, which I think is great.
AUDIENCE: So it
sounds like you've
been doing this, now,
the national parks
project, for about 25 years,
give or take, from '92.
So I know you also
mention more, lately,
you've been going
to backcountry.
So I was curious
if you've worked
on a project of
continuity at all,
or is it more just trying to
document as much as possible?
Or have you found yourself,
even season to season,
going back to the same
spots and trying to capture
a lot of the same images?
I'd add, as a
second part to that,
if you've noticed any changes
in those spots over the last 25
years?
QT LUONG: The things
that I do, actually,
when I return to
a park, I always
try to find something new.
And interestingly enough,
I thought that the project
would stop at one point.
But the thing is that the
more you know some things,
the more you realize that
there's some things that you
don't know.
And so I've been
exploring, I would say,
new corners of the park
that I hadn't seen before,
or new conditions, rather than
trying to return repeatedly
to the same spot.
But still, you know,
I did, from time
to time, return to the
same spot-- for instance,
to exit Glacier.
I've gone there four times.
And each time, what that has
taught me was glacial retreat.
So the first time
when I got there,
I was able to get to
the edge of the glacier.
And now, the glacier has
retreated hundreds of yards.
And then, there's
new valleys that
appeared which is very steep,
and you can't get closer.
So those changes are the
most striking that I've seen.
AUDIENCE: Which one is your
favorite national park?
QT LUONG: So that would
be a question which
would be difficult
to answer just
based on the merits of the
park because they're all
so different.
But for me, it's
an easy question
to answer if I answer it
based on my relationship
with the place.
And so it has to be
Yosemite because it was
the first place that I visited.
It's a park that I visited
more than any others.
I've done, probably, hundreds
of visits in that park, alone.
I've climbed, skied, hiked
in the park in all seasons,
so I've really developed a
relationship with the place.
AUDIENCE: If you
were to think back--
actually, let me
rephrase the question.
If somebody were to do this--
visit all the national
parks and take pictures--
what would your
advice to them be?
And on reflection, what
would you do differently?
QT LUONG: So if someone was to
visit all the national parks,
my advice would be
don't get ready to do
a single trip to a park and
expect to see everything.
So I see there's quite a
few folks, particularly
during the centennial,
they embark on a trip
where the goal was to visit
all the parks in a year
or something like that.
And I mean, it's something which
is fun to do but, actually,
on a single visit, you see
only one aspect of the park.
And I, personally, prefer
to come back to a park
several times rather
than making a long visit.
So that would be one
advice I would give.
What was the second
part of the question?
AUDIENCE: On reflection, what
would you do differently?
QT LUONG: What would
I do differently?
Yes.
What I would do
differently is that I
would take a much more
systematic approach
to photography in the
national parks in the sense
that, in the course
of a project,
I notice that there's
a number of themes that
began to develop that
I haven't showed you
in this presentation.
So I began to zero in on some
specific aspect of the parks--
the trees, close-up
of the grounds,
the night sky, even
grains of sand.
And so I found that,
because I didn't
begin to photograph those
subjects on my first visits--
even some parks after I'd
done three or four visit--
I still had to return to
complete those series.
So it's something that I
would have thought better
from the beginning.
SPEAKER: OK.
Well, thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]